bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end émission consacrée à vos
loisirs aux événements culturels et
justement l'événement culturel de ce
week-end cela se passe du côté de
trappes ce sera samedi soir une
compagnie new-yorkaise battery dance
company a animé pendant une semaine des
stages gratuits un spectacle restitution
sera donc donnée là samedi soir à la
merise retour sur cette semaine de
pratique artistique ouverte à tous
est bien loin
ils dansent s'exprime sous le regard
d'une chorégraphe américaine robin fait
partie de wall street dance company une
compagnie new-yorkaise qui six mois de
l'année arpente les villes du monde
entier pour proposer des stages de danse
et gratuit hier à belfast en irlande
demain à calcutta en inde et pendant
cette semaine de vacances ici à trappes
à l'école de musique et de danse pour
yasmine et cyrine que du bonheur
c'est bizarre parce que j'ai pas j'ai
jamais vu des danseurs américains et
c'est la première fois que j'en vois
est bas
mais ils sont gentils j'aime bien bouger
et montrer mon talent en fait et je
danse depuis tout petit ça soit la danse
classique hip hop etc déjà je vais
apprendre l'anglais mieux que ouais
j'apprends comme ça je sais des mots etc
et je peux encore m'entraîner encore
plus dans la danse
travailler en groupe d
et
savoir écouter autres et les idées des
autres
l'idée c'est de travailler de se
concentrer sur les forts ensemble
la cohésion de roues pour dépasser leurs
propres lignées se rendre compte qu'ils
pouvaient dance company a été créé en 76
dans un quartier assez défavorisé du sud
de manhattan les cinq danseurs
principaux qui composent la troupe sont
tous enseignants et chorégraphe ils ont
des origines très diverses clément et
ghanéens carmen et canadiennes chaîne
vient de la barbade mirail des texane
ici il apprécie aussi la mixité des
élèves
ce que je trouve formidable c'est la
variété du groupe qui est très
international en discutant avec les
élèves je me suis rendu compte qu'ils
venaient des quatre coins du monde
d'afrique de l'europe de partout donc
humainement c'est très enrichissant
cette diversité
une semaine de stage une représentation
unique et gratuite ce samedi soir à la
merise de trappes l'accomplissement de
cinq jours de travail et d'énergie mise
en commun
cette année ce sont les 20 ans de
l'espace rambouillet ans et pour en
parler avec nous angoisse graffin
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur des vieux
un espace qui est gérée par le nfc un
peu étonnant voire le nf gérer l'espace
rambouillet qui est un parc de loisirs
on va en parler dans quelques instants
bonsoir pas tant que ça parce qu'en fait
dans l'émission de nrj à la
sensibilisation à la nature et le fait
d'avoir l'espace rambouillet dans son
giron c'est une manière de faire
découvrir la forêt au grand public
pourquoi la création
alors su remonter un petit peu plus loin
dans le temps le parc animalier des
yvelines sur le même site avait été
créée dans les années 70 pour montrer
une grande densité d'animaux de nos
forêts et en 1994 l'espace rambouillet
sous sa forme actuelle a été créé avec
l'implantation d'une drôlerie et l'idée
je le répète c'était de
d'offrir et de faire découvrir au grand
public
la forêt avec ses habitantes est-ce
qu'on peut il voir dans ce parc qui fait
254 car l on voit des serres ont ce
qu'on voit les c'est en lisant on peut
même les entendre paramé mais il ya
autre chose aussi justement des oiseaux
alors en fait il s'étend sur 250
hectares et on peut y trouver les grands
animaux classique de nos forêts
tempérées cerfs chevreuils d'un sanglier
sur environ 200 hectares et puis aussi
les rapaces donc une trentaine d'espèces
qui sont
présentés au cours de démonstrations de
vol d'accord c'est ce qu'on voit c'est
toujours assez spectaculaire les rapaces
c'est spectaculaire parce que c'est une
des premières fois on a la possibilité
d'approcher
ces oiseaux qui passe très près de très
près des spectateurs c'est un parc est
ouvert pratiquement toute l'année en
france est fermé en janvier décembre
janvier on est fermé en décembre janvier
sinon le reste de l'année c'est ouvert
combien de personnes travaillent au
quotidien pour alors il ya une équipe de
permanents en fait de 15 personnes et
puis cette équipe c'est off un petit peu
pour les mois de nos grosses activités
qui vont commencer à partir d'avril et
qui jusqu'à jusqu'à octobre parce qu'en
terme de visiteurs à peu près combien de
personnes fréquentent le parc notamment
dans les périodes les plus mais plus
chargées j'ai envie de dire alors des
vacances
si on fait le bilan annuel ça revient à
peu près à 100 mille spectateurs par an
avec des pics jusqu'à 1500 voire 2000
visiteurs par jour
on le voit sur ces images vous avez
parlé de la forêt des aigles est aussi
la forêt sauvage avec les serres mais là
on a vu aussi de l'accrobranche pas
alors c'est un type d'accrobranche petit
la prévention parcours sécurisé sur les
passerelles dans les arbres vous êtes à
3 4 mètres de hauteur dans les arbres et
donc vous avez une sensation différente
la forêt se rapproche de l'ambiance
forestière c'est accessible à tous à
partir de 4 ans alors je les lycées sont
les vingt ans cette année il ya beaucoup
d'animations qui vont être faite autour
de ces ses 20 ans il y aura en plus des
animations qu'on connaît il y aura du
compte il y aura du théâtre aussi tout à
fait expositions sont les vingt ans
l'espace rambouillet et à 20 ans on aime
bien faire la fête et donc on a on
essaie de concocter un programme
d'événements avec des spectacles
associant deux des comédiens des rapaces
des expositions de photos de peintures
animalières des balades nocturnes et
puis aussi un week end armes de
collection qui va clôturer la saison fin
septembre et encore beaucoup d'autres
choses que vous pouvez retrouver sur le
sur le site qui va s'afficher en
quelques instants il ya aussi une sortie
dimanche 20 avril comme là c'est dans
deux jours qu'est-ce qu'on peut qu
est-ce qu on peut voir dans cette sortie
alors en fait ce sont des visites
guidées
dans la forêt sauvage pour découvrir les
différents milieux de la forêt sauvage
et puis ce pouvoir s'approcher des
animaux et de mieux comprendre leur
biologie leurs habitudes avec un guide
professionnel parce qu'on vous dit
approcher les animaux n'y a pas de
risque non effectivement on pourrait se
poser la question et notamment des
sangliers qui peuvent être parfois un
peu belliqueux quand on s'approche des
petits mais en vingt ans d'activité il
n'y a jamais eu d'accident donc je
touche du bois
pour que ça se voulait pas de problèmes
notamment avec les sangliers parce qu'on
parle qui sont assez envahissant il ya
de plus en plus envahissants comment
vous vous irez ça la population des
sangliers ou alors le cette gestion de
la population votre s'applique à
l'ensemble des espèces que que j'ai
cités sachant que l'espace est clos si
on fait rien du tout la population
augmenterait de 40 % par an donc on
limite cette population par des journées
de chasse dans l'année en décembre
janvier d'accord il s'appelait pour les
sangliers également pour les cerfs
sangliers cerfs chevreuils et d'un
d'accord en fait je reviens sur ces sur
ses 20 ans parmi tous les événements
pour la cité ce que vous avez un coup de
coeur
par le coup de coeur alors deux parce
que les coups de coeur c'est c'est le
spectacle en fait qui va associer les
comédiens et des rapaces qui va faire
aussi un voyage dans le temps sur sur la
forêt sa perception depuis
depuis le début du premier millénaire et
puis aussi l'évolution dans les saisons
et avec la première représentation le 14
juin qui sera le week end on fêtera
e
sans ce strict --elle anniversaire
voilà
je la dévoile d'accord à notre coup de
coeur
après un deuxième coup de coeur
peut-être en fin de saison sur 1 le
week-end d'art de collection ou hong
kong organise avec des pépiniéristes ont
fait ça aussi en partenariat avec
l'arboretum de la nf à nogent sur
vernisson qui nous apportera plein de
plans
valeur ornementale et moi j'ai déjà vu
en fait les plans qui sont en production
actuellement et c'est alléchant
ça c'est des coups de coeur d'envoi ce
graphe interne dernier mot les spa
seront vifs les dix est géré par parle
aux élèves quel est le rôle de l'eau est
neuf c'est ça c'est de réguler à la fois
la population
de la faune à la fois s'occuper
entretenir leur général oui mais en fait
c'est de la gestion forestière
assez large ce qui veut dire gérer la
production
assure une production des arbres mais
récolte au bon moment assurer sa
pérennité par le renouvellement et puis
s'occupait aussi de toute la vie qui est
qui résident dans ces espaces et donc il
faut protéger les espèces les animaux
l'espace végétal c'est un travail assez
assez générale pour la lettre ne
s'occupe que des forêts publiques
interdits
en forêt privée c'est quoi c'est la
majorité non non on a en france on est à
25 % en france métropolitaine 25 % de
forêts publiques et donc les trois
quarts restants va enfin vers l'ouest
restent privés merci beaucoup d'être
venu sur place de 7,8 week-end pour nous
parler et des 20 ans de l'espace
rambouillet et aussi de dons de ce parc
on peut dire par de loisirs oui enfin ce
mercredi au parc de loisirs nature et je
rappelle qu'il est ouvert en ce moment
tous les jours compter environ 12 euros
50 pour un adulte et 9 euros 50 pour un
enfant de moins de 12 ans voilà vous
savez tout merci beaucoup d'être venus
et direction maintenant guyancourt à la
découverte des héroïnes les héroïnes qui
sont mises en lumière à l'occasion d'un
atelier de films d'animation mathieu
bide en fait le point
concentration minutie il faut de la
patience pour réaliser un film
d'animation
l'artiste julie dumont l'a expliqué aux
curieux venus donner vie aux héroïnes de
leur quotidien elle s'anime grâce aux
nouveaux outils technologiques vue
classé en comité réduit g
j'ai essayé de montrer un peu un maximum
de choses qui existent aujourd'hui et y
en a de plus en plus là en l'occurrence
est le plus simple la technique du stop
motion image par image avec un appareil
photo avec l'exposition héroïne la femme
est à l'honneur pour ce petit atelier se
sont-elles les têtes d'affiché un
hommage important pour brigitte qui
découvrent l'animation aujourd'hui c'est
l'histoire de ma grand mère qui était
une sacrée bonne femme est aussi le
sacré grand mère donc c'est ce que
j'essaye de mettre en image de façon un
petit peu
drôle voilà avec un fond neutre un
appareil photo et quelques idées il est
possible de réaliser son petit film
d'animation pour brigitte il est surtout
question de souvenirs et de transmission
c'est très sain mes filles à ma mère
encore ma grand mère est décédée je
pourrai pas lui montrer sa part les
voiles à concrétiser des choses de
l'histoire familiale les apprentis
réalisateurs sont repartis avec un petit
film d'une dizaine de secondes de quoi
s'amuser en famille
allez cette information culture pour
continuer richard bohringer devait être
sur la scène du prisme est elle en cours
mardi 29 avril en raison des ennuis de
santé du comédien la production bardot a
décidé d'annuler tous les spectacles de
la tournée et le spectacle de l'encours
est donc également annulé la direction
du prisme nous a fait savoir qu'elle
était dans l' attente d'informations de
la part de la production pour
éventuellement repousser la date en
septembre ou en octobre des spectateurs
qui ont pris leurs billets seront bien
évidemment tenu au courant ce week-end
le temps s'annonce un peu grise
peut-être l'occasion justement d'aller
au cinéma l'avis des spectateurs sur les
derniers films qui viennent de sortir au
micro des redifs moi c'était très bien
j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est assez drôle
donc après je conseille d'aller voir
pour ceux qui aiment bien les films un
peu humoristique et ce qu'on aimait very
bad trip est assez drôle si le français
sans surprise mais marrant on va dire
face à bromont c'était sympa on passe un
bon moment le c'est excellent ça se
passe dans la bonne humeur heures ça
détruit des préjugés et s'est
merveilleusement bien joué génial très
très bien et c'est bien il ya plein de
choses
trop pour assister ces fera très bien où
on va on va toutes les infos toutes les
couleurs de comédie d'un arc en ciel
c'est un beau film et j'ai des surprises
pour un film français c'était assez
amusant c'était c'était très bien très
amusant bonne réplique bon jeu d'acteurs
du père qui s'était super bien et puis
si t'es marrant je sais trés trés bien
intéressant de voir ce film pour les
cultures les différentes cultures et je
trouve que c'est vraiment on passe un
très bon moment c'est traité avec
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de réalisme
vraiment bien aimé quand tu es vraiment
un bon moment et puis avant de se
quitter quelques idées de sorties pour
ce week-end et évidemment tous les
regards se portent vers la chasse aux
oeufs on commence par le château de
breteuil la chasse aux oeufs est ouverte
de10 dimanche et lundi avec deux départs
à 12h30 et l'autre à 17 heures à
rambouillet l'idée originale de chasse
aux oeufs à la bergerie nationale une
course d'orientation est proposé aux
enfants pour retrouver les fameuses en
chocolat et c'est tous les jours de 14h
à 17h30 et puis c'est également une
tradition la chasse aux oeufs à voisins
le bretonneux donc cette fois lundi 21
avril des milliers de seront dissimulés
bien caché dans le parc de la croix du
bois pour récompenser tous ces chasseurs
un goûter sera offert en fin
d'après-midi et une animation zumba
ouverte aux familles la mare attention
départ de la course on me l'a précisé à
16 heures très précises ne faut pas
manquer le départ de la course cette
édition du 7 au 8 week-end est terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi profitez bien de
ce week-end à pascal et à très vite